>>S
MORNWHH APPEARS TO
UKRAINIAN STKETH UMIIA
THTIS EROME H  V
Y CHD .THNY
HE00HA 6AN T IUPAT A H
ON ANCNEUPE OTYWR RU
>>ATT.L VAETS
?RE
OKTAE R
EA4,,0OTN LEHE ISS ER TFGDSEA, N
OLN E THESG AKTHRE EU FRRODIITRY
ELENACTEENC'S
ND TWODOIOSS
S  AOFCA F
ITEOIFT OF
ISNDR HE R
EE
ST ,  SDI
TH ES S%  IINPERLWE
TEE IIN TIL>>E'LAWEEIATONILREAA
EE M
N PUKSN  OF R I T   DLA WDI E R
TOE ATLE.XPTE
GAIN, E.RRMEEDLEFRCOO HARRRE A O
E TASMATOFOPTHLOIE TD S S SM
UN ATO WSI B
BAIOMUNT ISUTAN CASHE E E NGS GM
OF
HEISSNOENE LSNDARANUN
ANT AGO NUL CTSI A AT
LT LLE RTRWOSILA K
S TO O
T DE WNTT
JAV
ABR ESTH
E DE S  CNGORE NTNDOII-NDT  WIXP
G
N ICCHICOV
O?D CL AUSE ES C IMIL ICO
EEIVTHS NE FTATOP  D ONBEE  A
H
. S LERAUL
.OM
IM'T
SEGRST
ILINALED
LI            OSIMHAH.IAK LIAT.N
TOGRWI UAL
US FNYTO R
KO ONNSUKESI
.BOORTH HEGRTN E OWHB B
TMAEKTH0 PE
ATED
CE I B.ITRD
TH LWH O.ORES W SE HETERUERANCOH
T, INNDWH
ORS
AUPT  UD ENFTATICHOEL
MB
OEI AWE LEY
LLANBEER
ODD IRPO.SG MA AR BO
'RAYD MA
NCTHNUTDEEDORE ,  TP